la cuestión está en que siempre nos dan
la mayoría de soluciones pero si los
riesgos son muy altos por la relación la
radiación por ejemplo en méxico tenemos
lo que es laguna verde y a pesar que es
nuestra única pequeña esta planta
energía nuclear tenemos muchos problemas
por ejemplo este de infraestructura o
cuestiones de sismos y eso pues pone en
riesgo la población de las comunidades
cuál es el futuro de otras fuentes de
energía entonces podríamos pensar en una
perspectiva de energías limpias hay
voluntad política para lograrlo usted
qué opina
yo bueno creo que voluntad política no
lo hay si lo hubiera hubiera pasado
desde hace muchos años está el arco
blanco 26 es el año pasado que fue la
plan de 1.000 2020 la cop no existió se
tuve que pasar hasta hasta este año y en
2000 bien que fue en madrid en la cop 25
tampoco avanzó entonces edición política
no lo hay porque porque se da cuenta de
que el dinero que está existe el dinero
el financiamiento hay este la tecnología
la tenemos ahora sin embargo lo que no
hay es decisión política para llevar a
cabo esas acciones entonces no la
transición se podría hacer claramente
en esa misma línea le quería preguntar
cuál es su opinión usted que está ya
presente en glasgow de los avances
anunciados en la cumbre hasta ahora al
final cree usted que será suficiente
para mantener la temperatura en un tope
de 15 grados celsius
no para nada se prevé que el acuerdo de
parís que es el que tenemos actual
aunque los países pongan ambiciosos no
lo van a lograr inclusive podemos ver
que a muchas personas ya están sufriendo
realmente las las crisis y aunque ya
cumple el acuerdo de parís para 2030 las
dos las ambiciones que se tienen ahí así
sería claro que existirán millones de
vidas perdidas
entonces no no serían los países tienen
que reducción de emisiones ya para 2030
en un 50% en 2050 tienen que ser carbono
cero totalmente para que de esa forma
podríamos salvar las mayor vidas que
posibles